Carlos do you have a question for Conan
you know I know that your superhero
Persona was the Flaming C yes your
stripper Persona is Ginger Snap yep so
what would your track name be well I'm
first of all you stole it it was going
to be red velvet so now I have to find a
different uh sort of you know like
polyester red polyester red polyester I
don't know I'm looking for something
other than velvet velvet's expensive and
I don't want to perform in velvet every
night well it doesn't have to be like a
fabric oh okay sorry I didn't know what
what I don't know
right you know a lot of them are just
like fun puns they're alter egos well
help me out here I don't know I'm I'm
new to this world I need to know what I
would be who do you want to be like uh
yeah would you have a Persona like you
know he's kind of you know the Wendy's
girl the logo yeah oh boy yeah she is
doesn't she have a name Wendy Wendy
does Ronald McDonald have a name
I thought she no I think I would be uh I
think yeah if I mean first of all I have
to avoid any I'd have to work out a deal
with the Wendy's uh franchise but I'm
sure they'd have no problem with it
who's Wendy I think the Wendy's girl
because I've got that coloring I've got
the reddish hair and Wendy's nuts
Wendy's nuts Wendy's not okay Wendy's
Wendy's nuts I don't know if I'm at a
drag show and I see someone called
Wendy's nuts coming up I'm gonna be like
I'm gonna skip that one I know who Wendy
yeah you know what I'm sorry okay I
thought she as a character was somebody
else but I just realized I thought the
guy was like Bob Wendy oh my God I'm
sorry Carlos ah you uh you're seeing us
at our very worst I apologize yeah maybe
uh it's yeah Wendy's is it Wendy's nuts
I don't know because I think when you
hear when you hear nuts you don't want
to see that at a drag show you know when
you can be just win this O'Brien no no
it's got to be something else
[Music]
wild and windy pass good podcasting yeah
it's pretty tight stay wild and Wendy
like a drug name is something very
intimate what'd you say a dragon name is
something actually quite more intimate
than to find like with me it was when I
came with it Afra I went to a friend
it's like I got it it's red velvet this
is great and he said no it's terrible
it's not enough for a drag queen and
it's too much for a stripper and I said
well that's perfect for me yeah so you
need to find that glint in your eye yeah
this is going to take time and this is
going to take time and we'll probably
have to ask our fans to suggest a really
good drag name for my character I think
that's what we should do because yeah
it's open source because I don't know
and um and I don't think we're gonna get
clearance from uh Wendy to use the name
Wendy longstock and that's very Wendy
too so I don't even know if kids anymore
know about Pippi Longstocking I guess we
need clearance just to use the name
Wendy in it's just a well because I
would I would that would be your persona
I would rip off for a look oh okay no uh
I don't know we're gonna figure this out
we're gonna figure this out you know and
then I guess I'll have to you know have
no choice but to build the costume and
then perform uh in Drag and in drag
shows uh in in London yes come join the
house of cupcake because our drag house
is named after my horse not after me so
you know we are a big group of
performers and we do a we produce our
own shows now so you're very welcome to
join our next show us as our guest drag
queen whatever the name is all right I'm
looking forward to this I'd like to see
no I wouldn't yeah I don't I don't
really I'd like to see their show but uh
you don't want to see me in Drag
me when you put the heels in you change
yeah well first of all if I wore heels
I'd be six nine jeez so I really I
really would change but also I make a
very attractive woman
you do I do oh definitely yeah I'm more
attractive as a woman than as a man is
that right yes usually that's usually
true yeah yeah yeah I make I'm a very
stunning woman I'm statuesque and I have
a lot of legs very I have legs that go
on forever I don't know I've seen you
with makeup on yeah it's it's just guy
makeup like Japanese remote where you
visited that District of Japan and you
got that kind of yeah but I wasn't in
charge of that I would do oh man America
I killed it I was beautiful looking at
the end Conan it was gorgeous oh you
looked like you had been in an accident
like you looked really hurt he looked
hurt okay well anyway this is devolving
that sounds like a good look
maybe that's your theme maybe yeah
red mess oh yeah yeah just red pavement
redness red asphalt that's what it is
yeah red asphalt I'm just someone I'm my
whole Persona is I just wiped out on my
motorcycle going 90 miles an hour and
I'm wearing no body armor yeah and I
rode my face for 20 yards red asphalt
and your tagline of your show is Scared
Straight yeah there you go we've worked
at all that's an act that's an act right
there